I was the kind of kid in high school who
did the entire high school newspaper on
the kitchen table and used fake names
for other pieces and I never met anybody
like this until 25 years later I went to
do a piece about the forward the Yiddish
newspaper and Yiddish of course is a
dying language and those who still speak
Yiddish for the most part of Hasidic and
want nothing to do with this formerly
socialist paper and the old man who
still did this newspaper did the same
thing he was doing it basically in his
little office and he and three
colleagues did the whole paper that was
much like the newspaper that I put
together in high school I went to a high
school called Pascack Valley High School
and we were the Indians even to this day
they're the Indians
though no Indians in sight and of course
the newspaper was called wait for it the
smoke signal you get a communication -
smoke signal Indians it's amazing it's
still legal I should also say that that
journalism for me was two things it was
a way of seeing the world and getting
out and traveling and forcing myself to
meet other people and see other things
and and to know something that was the
way I could bring myself to know
something there's no I'm not a scholar
and didn't have a scholarly temperament
and it was also a way to make a living
you know I you know came from a family
where I knew I would have to absolutely
make a living if not even support my
parents because if illnesses and things
like that and so the idea of setting up
shop after college and writing a novel
and hoping for the trust fund to kick in
that wasn't going to happen
and
so in college the jobs I had was not
waiting on tables but being a stringer
for other newspapers writing the same
obituary ten times or writing about a
basketball game or a fire or a crime or
or this or that anything I was in you
know my addiction came early and and I
learned a lot from I was an intern at
the Washington Post and and then I
wasn't they said go away and and and the
other newspaper in town had folded the
Washington star quite a good newspaper
so they didn't need you know X college
students they needed the best they could
grab from the store and I went and
taught in Japan which was rather like
being a cast member in stripes rice lice
rice lies back and forth it was a
ridiculous job I came back was an intern
again at at the post and I worked very
very very very hard and even thought I
did okay and so maybe I'll land a job
here and what happened was as I asked
for a meeting with the then managing
editor Howard Simons who if you saw all
the president's men was played by Martin
balsam
and I said I just five minutes if I
could get five minutes of your time and
in fact he took me to lunch and for two
and a half hours Howard Simons
complained about his job how Ben Bradley
got all the credit and how somehow all
the President's Men wasn't an accurate
portrayal of the great role that he had
played and so on
two hours of this and I'm I don't know
eleven years old I was twenty-one we
came back to the office and he said but
of course you wanted something right you
know he's playing do you like a little
mouse which I was I said yes I'd love to
stay here and continue working here as
it as a reporter and he said well the
post owns a newspaper in Everett
Washington Everett Washington I said mr.
Simons there are no Jews in Everett wash
and he exploded with laughter and when
he finished peeling himself off the
ceiling he said well you can start on on
Mondays as a night police reporter which
is as jobs go is the lowest of the low
and especially the post as opposed to a
tabloid but that's where I started and
I'm so I was unbelievably lucky I
started at The Washington Post is you
know one of the two great really lucky
two or three great lucky things that
happened to me in my career the other
lucky thing was in about 1987 there was
a notice that went up on the board and
it said we're looking for a Moscow
correspondent and what that always means
I thought at a newspaper was that the
job had already been filled but they had
to formally put this on the board
in fact they hadn't filled it because as
it turns out Russia is really cold very
cold no one would particularly wanted to
live there and the post was adding this
number two person the only foreign
correspondent not to be a bureau chief
and so I put my name forward and because
of the one subject worried and really
really poorly in college was Russian
therefore I got that job and as it
obviously turned out I went for the
probably the four most exalted least
violent most positive years in the
history of the Russian Empire which are
88 89 90 91 and I lived there and it was
a postcard